Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Es wird allerhöchste Zeit, endlich mal wieder über die 2. Liga zu sprechen, heute mit einem kleinen Schwerpunkt auf dem HSV. Und ich begrüße dazu bei mir einen altbekannten Forumsnutzer, Patrick. Patrick, schön, dass du mal hier im Rasenfunk bist. Mensch, vom Rezipienten und sehr sehr aktiven Twitterer und Schreiberling im Forum jetzt mal zum Gast im Rasenfunk. Ich dachte, ich probiere das einfach mal, weil mir deine Beiträge, die du als et saure Hefe 1887 da abgesetzt hast, so gut gefallen haben. Ich bin gespannt, wie es dir jetzt mal auf der anderen Seite gefällt.
Ja, ich bin auch gespannt. Ich war schon in ein, zwei HSV-Podcasts mal zu Gast, aber das hier ist ja dann nochmal was anderes. Da geht es ja auch um andere Themen.
Nee, nee, hinterher kommt jetzt noch die Nervosität. Die brauchst du nicht. Vor allem nicht, weil wir die Tabelle von oben nach unten durchgehen und wir dann nämlich gleich mit deinem Herzensthema anfangen können, nämlich mit dem Hamburger SV. Fünf Spiele sind gespielt. Der HSV gehört zu drei Mannschaften, die noch ungeschlagen sind nach diesen fünf Spielen. Vier Siege, ein Unentschieden, 13 zu drei Tore, 13 Punkte. Und alles sieht wunderbar aus im hohen Norden. Was macht denn Dieter Hecking anders oder ist das jetzt eine Momentaufnahme? Was ist mit dem HSV passiert?
Ja, also erstmal muss ich sagen, dass das wirklich runter wie Öl geht, dass nochmal alles hintereinander zu hören. Da kann man sich ja nach den letzten Jahren langsamer dran gewühlen. Also es wäre super, wenn das so bleiben würde. Was anders läuft beim HSV ist einfach, ich glaube, wir können direkt bei den Spielern ansetzen. Wir haben in der Startelf haben wir sieben neue Zugänge, erneut Zugänge. Und von der Elf, die letztes Jahr so schandhaft in den Medien gesprochen, den Aufstieg verpasst hat, sind eigentlich nur noch die Innenverteidiger und die Außenmannspieler die gleichen wie im letzten Jahr. Wir haben einen neuen Torwart, neuer Außenverteidiger, komplett neues Mittelfeld und eine neue Sturmspitze. Und auch auf der Bank noch einige neue Spieler. Also wir haben quasi eine komplett neue Elf. Also die könnte man auch genau positionsgetreu aufstellen, wenn alle fit wären. Und ich glaube, da hat es so ein bisschen so ein neuer Geist eingekehrt. Mit eben Dieter Hecking, der ein sehr solider Verwalter ist, der das wunderbar moderiert. Ich glaube, das hat man auch ein bisschen mitbekommen in der Kausa Jatta, dass er einfach super gelassen ist und im Moment einfach nur die richtigen Worte findet. Und da kann man als HSV-Fan eigentlich gerade, ja, da kann man einfach nur zufrieden sein.
Ja, über die Kausa Jatta würde ich gerne dann auch noch kurz mit dir sprechen. Aber lass vorher mal bei den ganzen Transfers bleiben. Wenn ich mir mal angucke, wer da gekommen ist, dann haben wir David Kinsombi von Heustern Kiel, Xavier Amaci von der U23 von Arsenal, Everton vom 1. FC Nürnberg, Tim Leibold ebenfalls vom Club Berkay Ötztan vom VfB, Daniel Heuer-Fernandez von Darmstadt 98, Lukas Hinterseher, Sonny Kittel, der jetzt schon vier Tore erzielt hat in diesen fünf Zweitligapartien, vom FC Ingolstadt, Martin Harnik, Jeremy Dudzak, Jan Czarmarra. Also da geht es noch ein bisschen weiter. Ist das jetzt auch schon eine gewisse Handschrift von Jonas Boll, die man bei diesen Neuzugängen sehen kann? Sind das alles für sich genommen gute Kicken? Gibt es da irgendwas, was die vereint? Kann man da irgendwie sagen, es gibt jetzt eine Philosophie in der Transferpolitik?
Also das sind nicht alles Boll-Transfers. Einige wurden halt auch schon von Becker eingefädelt, so Spieler wie Hinterseher oder Kinsombi. Da war man schon in den Verhandlungen bzw. hat die auch schon abgeschlossen. Was diese ganze Mannschaft eint, ist, dass das größtenteils Spieler sind, die die 2. Liga schon kennen. Das heißt, das sind einigermaßen junge und entwicklungsfähige Spieler noch, die so von Mitte 20 bis Ende 20 – also Hinterseher ist ja der älteste Neuzugang von denen, die gerade spielen. Die anderen sind alle so Mitte 20, kennen die 2. Und sie haben aber auch noch ein Entwicklungspotenzial. Das heißt, ich nehme das jetzt mal in den Mund, sollte man aufsteigen. Da müsste man die nicht alle direkt wieder loswerden oder da müsste einem nicht Angst und Bange werden.
Adrian Fein habe ich noch vergessen. Der wurde aus der Reserve der Bayern von den Amateuren verliehen. Er hat nach dem, was ich so gesehen habe, in der 2. Liga beim HSV schon auch einige ganz gute Auftritte hingelegt. Was ist denn wichtiger, die Zugangsseite oder vielleicht sogar in diesem speziellen Fall die Abgangsseite? Denn wenn ich mir angucke, Douglas Santos, Philipp Kostet, gut, den hat man natürlich ein bisschen weinenden Auges abgegeben, Fiete Aab, Gotoko Sakai, Pierre-Michel La Sorga. Also da sind ja viele Namen jetzt gegangen worden, gegangen vom HSV, mit denen man diesen Verein verbunden hat.
Ja genau, da hast du was Richtiges angesprochen. Das hat man ja jetzt schon mehrfach in den letzten Jahren gemacht, dass man den Kader grunderneuert hat. Man hat ja in den letzten fünf Jahren vor dem Abstieg schon des Öfteren um den Abstieg gebettelt und den Kader zwei- bis dreimal komplett auf links gedreht. Was eben geblieben ist, das war die Leistung und das war oft auch die Verunsicherung in der Mannschaft. Und jetzt hat man wirklich auch nochmal Spiele abgegeben. Das musste man allein schon aus finanzieller Sicht tun, also ein La Sorga und ein Holtby. Die kann man einfach nicht mehrere Jahre in der 2. Liga mitschleppen, vor allen Dingen nicht, wenn man sieht, was die für Leistung gebracht haben. Dann so Spieler wie Sakai sind so ein bisschen eine andere Geschichte. Die sind auch als Führungsspieler natürlich dafür verantwortlich, dass es nicht so geklappt hat, aber das war ja dann ein bisschen nicht wirklich rumreich, wie er sich dann verabschieden musste, weil die Fans ihn eben zum Sündenbock auserkoren hatten. Der hat sich wirklich bis zum Ende, der ist ja recht spät gewechselt, hat er sich noch um die Neuzugänge gekümmert. Als ehemaliger Kapitän hat er versucht, die alle einzugliedern und ihnen Platz in der Mannschaft zu verschaffen und ist dann ganz spät nach Japan zurück. Da muss man wirklich den Hut vorziehen. Aber letztendlich, du kannst eben, du musst mit dem arbeiten, was du hast und ich glaube, dass Dieter Hecking, der hat das gut gemacht, dass er da jetzt eben in so kurzer Zeit schon so eine konstante Mannschaft hingekriegt hat. Also wir haben da einen Chor von 15 bis 16 Spielern, Moment nur. Das könnte natürlich irgendwann noch mal zum Problem werden, aber aktuell weiß jeder seine Rolle und aktuell funktioniert es sehr gut.
Okay, also das ist das neue Gesicht des Kaders. Wie sieht es denn auf dem Spielfeld aus? Was für ein Fußball lässt Hecking spielen und wer sind da so die entscheidenden Spieler?
Genau. In den letzten Jahren bzw. in den letzten Jahren ist übertrieben. Im letzten Jahr in der 2. Liga hat man ja so ein bisschen das Bild des HSV gesehen, der sehr viel Ballbesitz hatte, sehr viel den Ball hin und her geschoben hat, aber sehr torungefährlich war. Man hatte nicht viele Tore für den Aufschiegskandidaten. Man hat eine verlässliche Defensive gehabt, das war gut. Deswegen konnte man sich auch oben lange halten. Aber nach vorne ging wenig, sowohl unter Titz als auch unter Wolf, auch wenn es jeweils andere Gründe hatte. Und bei Hecking hat man wirklich das Gefühl, da gibt es ein paar neue Facetten in dem Spiel. Zum einen die Vertikalität, also man versucht häufig tief zu spielen, eben auf die Außenverteidiger, die aufrücken, oder Spieler wie Kintz Zombie und Dudziak, die aus dem zentralen Mittelfeld in die Halbräume, in den Strafraum eindringen. Man versucht auch zu kombinieren, also man ist sehr flügellastig durch eben starke Dribblingsspieler wie Jatta und Narei und die starken Außenverteidiger. Aber man kombiniert zum einen nicht um des Kombinierens willen, also man behält sein Ziel im Auge und man flankt nicht dauernd. Wir haben eine der wenigsten Flankenraten in der Liga, nur 13 Flanken pro Spiel. Ich wusste, dass dir das gefallen wird. Man merkt wirklich in jedem Spiel, wie man es so 2-3 Mal schafft, auf die Grundlinie zu kommen und dann aber flach zurückzulegen, wie es ja z.B. in der 1. Liga auch Dortmund in einer natürlich viel höheren Qualität öfter schafft. Aber dadurch kriegt man in jedem Spiel so 2-3 Chancen. Und was auch eine neue Facette des Spiels vom HSV ist, ist die Gefährlichkeit aus der 2. Reihe. Wir erzielen sehr viele Tore an und um den Strafraumrand. Da haben wir einfach mit Kittel, Dudziak, Leibold, Narey, der ist auch oft versucht, einfach sehr viele Spieler, die einen starken Abschluss haben. Und wenn du eben nach den Keyplayern oder nach den Schlüsselspielern gefragt hast, die eben für dieses System unabdingbar sind, dann ist es eben Adrian Fein, über den wir schon gesprochen haben. Der ist wirklich der Dreh- und Angelpunkt auf der Sechs. Leider natürlich nur für ein Jahr geliehen. Da muss man mal gucken, was da geht. Aber durch ihn hat man wirklich das Gefühl, dass man wenig quer spielt, weil er selber gerne sich sofort mit dem Ball nach vorne dreht, ein kurzes Dribbling ansetzt und dann eben den Ball verteilt. Das macht er richtig stark. Und ja, dann kann man eben, muss man auch Kittel und Hinterseher loben. Hinterseher ist so ein beweglicher Stürmer und geht immer wieder auf den Flügel, spielt dann aber auch richtig nette Pässe, so Chip-Pässe, die man ihm gar nicht so zutraut, wenn man ihn sieht. Und Kittel ist halt eingeschlagen wie eine Bombe. Also der hat ja schon vier Tore und eine Vorlage gemacht. Der fühlt sich richtig wohl, sowohl auf dem Flügel als auch auf der Acht hat er gespielt. Ich wünsche mir, dass er im zentralen Mittelfeld erstmal bleibt. Und ja, ansonsten, wie gesagt, im Moment kann man halt fast alle loben, da man ja 13 Punkte aus fünf Spielen hat und es alles gut funktioniert.
Das erste Unentschieden, das eine Unentschieden war zum Auftakt in die Saison. Da habe ich auch die Spiele näher verfolgt, sowohl das DFB-Pokalspiel gegen Chemnitz gerade so irgendwie noch weitergekommen, als auch dann den Auftakt gegen Darmstadt. Und bei den Spielen, die ich jetzt vom HSV gesehen habe, bei denen wenigen, wo es Gegentreffer gab, hatte ich aber noch den Eindruck, dieses eine ist noch geblieben aus der letzten Saison. Aber es war auch eine Verunsicherung, wenn man ein Tor gefangen hat. Also, dass man dann diese Ruhe, die du beschrieben hast, die man sonst in vielen Spielen sehen konnte, die hat in solchen Momenten dann manchmal noch gefehlt. Würdest du mir da zustimmen?
Ja, ich finde, das hast du gut beobachtet. Also, wenn es so eine Sache gibt, die halt noch so ein bisschen aus der letzten Saison da ist, dann eben zum einen, dass nach Gegentoren, dass man da so wirklich so eine Unruhe spürt und die Mannschaft ein bisschen braucht, um sich zu fangen. Das muss nicht immer negativ ausgehen. Also, wir haben auch in Karlsruhe 3-0 geführt und dann hat Karlsruhe brachial angegriffen, Ball um Ball in unseren Strafraum geschlagen und ist noch zum 2-3 rangekommen. Und letztendlich konnten wir das Spiel zum Glück noch für uns entscheiden. Aber wenn du auch die Spiele vom Anfang der Saison ansprichst, da hat man dann gesehen, wir tun uns natürlich immer noch schwer bei Rückstand oder bei Spielen gegen tiefstehende Gegner. Aber ich glaube, davon kann sich kein Zweitligist frei machen. Und auch viele Erstligisten haben ähnliche Probleme. Das ist jetzt ein krasser Vergleich, aber wenn man so sieht, wie Dortmund bei Union Berlin aufgetreten ist oder wie sich die Nationalmannschaft in Nordirland schwer tut, dann ist das halt vom Favoriten zu Außenseitergrad so oft so eine Konstellation, wie wir sie in der 2. Liga auch haben. Natürlich spielen wir die Gegner nicht in Grund und Boden, aber man hat es mittlerweile geschafft, dass man trotzdem so 3, 4 Hochkaräter pro Spiel sich rausspielt. Und da wir im Moment eine einigermaßen gute Chancenverwertung haben und oftmals auch früh treffen, kommen wir gar nicht so oft in so Situationen, dass der Gegner sich mit 10 Mann einigeln kann.
Und dann haben wir noch diese Kampagne gegen Bakary Jatta gehabt von Seiten der Springerpresse. Wie es ausgegangen ist, konnten wir jetzt alle nachvollziehen. Welchen Einfluss hat das denn deiner Meinung nach auf die sportlichen Leistungen des HSV gehabt? Da war ja durchaus exklusives Material oder da war die Möglichkeit, dass das sich richtig auch im Negativen auswirkt, ja schon drin, fand ich.
Ja, also das kann ich gut verstehen. Das war in Hamburg auch so ein Schlüsselmoment jetzt. Man sieht es halt so langsam, dass der Verein immer souveräner mit allen möglichen Themen umgeht, sei es jetzt auf oder außerhalb des Platzes. Und es hat sich einfach gut angefühlt, wie komplett die Mannschaft sowohl auf dem Trainingsplatz während des Spiels, aber auch irgendwie privat auf Instagram oder so. Also kann man sagen, was man will, aber sie haben sich alle mit Bakkeri Jatta solidarisiert und ihn immer wieder in ihre Mitte genommen. Jatta selber hat sich natürlich am schwersten damit getan. Da muss man nicht drum herum reden. Der hatte schon Spiele, der hat immer wieder aufblitzen lassen, was er eigentlich kann, aber man hat dann schon oft gesehen oder man hatte so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass wir ihn durchgeschleppt haben. Weil er ist halt so ein Spieler, da würde ich jetzt sagen, der denkt gar nicht so viel nach, wenn er den Ball hat. Der läuft einfach, da weiß nicht zu 100 Prozent, was er machen wird. Damit kommt er halt oft am Gegner vorbei. Das ist halt ein bisschen chaotisch oder wie nennt man das so schön?
Kreativ kann man im Positiven auch sagen.
Jeder Fan hat gesagt, mittlerweile haben sich die Leute schon gefragt, ob Hacking ihm mal ein, zwei Spiele draußen lassen wird. Dann hat sich das ja zum Glück relativ fix geklärt mit den Einsprüchen und mit dem DFB, sodass er jetzt erstmal keine Gefahr mehr hat, dass da was groß hochkommt. Man hat gesehen mit dem Tor, was für eine Explosion das war. Ich hoffe, das befreit ihn. Aber so eine Geschichte wird natürlich immer wieder hochkommen. Sei es, wenn einzelne Fan-Gruppen das aufgreifen oder wenn irgendwelche Zeitungen noch mal Artikel bringen. Man kann schon sagen, dass das ein bisschen sogar die Truppe zusammengeschweißt hat und vielleicht auf den Platz und sportlich einander näher gebracht hat. Na ja, damit kann man aber natürlich nicht alles legitimieren.
Klar, logisch. Aber das ist ja interessant zu sehen, wie sich sowas auswirken kann. Dann haben wir jetzt als Höhepunkt des sechsten Spieltags das Derby gegen St. Pauli in St. Pauli, also auswärts für den HSV. Ich kann mich an das Touhou wa Boho vor beiden Derbys in der letzten Saison erinnern. Das war bis hier unten nach München zu spielen, auch eine gewisse Genervthalt davon. In meiner Welt gibt es jetzt gar nicht so viel Herumgetöse vor diesem Spiel. Ist das ein bisschen ruhiger als im letzten Jahr, oder liegt das jetzt an meiner Filterblase, die das nicht mitbekommt?
Nee, da hast du schon recht. Man muss ja sehen, dass das jetzt irgendwie sieben Jahre das Derby nicht gab. Natürlich waren alle Seiten heiß wie Frittenfett. St. Pauli als kleinerer Verein hatte Lust, uns mal wieder in die Suppe zu spucken. Wir der HSV mussten natürlich die Stadtmeisterschaft erringen. Jetzt hat man im letzten Jahr ein bisschen gelernt, dass man das Spiel nicht überhöhen sollte. Das Hinspiel war ein absoluter Grottenkick. 0-0. Das Rückspiel war ein klarer Sieg für den HSV. Aber beide Mannschaften haben danach fast nichts mehr geholt. Das war wahrscheinlich der Höhepunkt der Saison. Man hat gesehen, wo das endet. In dieser Saison ist es ein bisschen ruhiger. Ich habe schon von Fans gehört, die sich ein bisschen beschwert haben und gesagt haben, hoffentlich uploadieren die uns jetzt nicht auch noch, weil die St. Paulianer sich sehr solidarisch mit Jatta gezeigt haben. Mehr Hack ist der Ausdruck, den ich in meiner Timeline gelesen habe. Es ist schon ein bisschen Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen. Ich denke, auf dem Platz wird es Montag hoch hergehen. Schönes Flutlichtspiel mitten in der Stadt. Aber wir sind der klare Favorit. Da muss man sehen, was wir draus machen.
Und wie es danach weitergeht. Das war in der letzten Saison wirklich bemerkenswert. Aber wir haben da ja auch schon einen Zweitliga-Kurzpässe thematisiert. Dann lassen wir noch ein bisschen die Tabelle weiter durchgehen und auf ein paar Vereine eingehen, die da ins Auge stechen. Allen voran der VfB, der auch ohne Niederlage bisher durch die Saison geht und auf Platz 2 hinter dem HSV liegt. 2 Unentschieden, 3 Siege, 8 zu 5 Tore, also deutlich weniger erzielt als der HSV. Wie gefällt dir denn der Absteiger, auf den du bestimmt auch ein besonderes Auge werfen wirst?
Ja, Stuttgart ist natürlich einer der Hauptkonkurrenten im Aufstiegskampf. Wenn man sieht, was die an Geld eingenommen haben durch ihre Verkäufe und was sie sich dafür geholt haben, wie der Kader so aussieht, dass eigentlich jede Position doppelt besetzt ist, dann ist Stuttgart für mich das, was Köln in der letzten Saison war, nämlich der klare Favorit auf den Aufstieg. Man muss natürlich sehen, der Kader wurde sehr durchgewirbelt und man hat einen neuen Trainer mit Tim Walther, der die Liga zwar schon kennt, aber der was ganz anderes spielen lässt, als das, was Stuttgart bisher gespielt hat. Wenn man das alles so zusammennimmt und dann sieht, dass Stuttgart schon elf Punkte hat, noch nicht verloren hat, dass die größten Probleme eher so Sachen wie die Chancenauswertung. Sind, und die Konteranfälligkeit, dann sehe ich eigentlich positiv für die Stuttgarter, also dass es eher besser wird als schlechter. Im Gegensatz zu uns jetzt vielleicht, wo man schon sieht, dass viel ineinander greift, sehe ich ja bei Stuttgart, da noch einige Sachen vor allem im Mittelfeld, wo ja sehr viele verschiedene Charaktere versuchen Spielzeit zu ergattern, in dieser sehr flexiblen Raute. Ein paar Verletzungen hatten sie ja auch schon. Und eben so Spieler wie Gomez, die da, wie Bad Stuber, die immer mal wieder für eine Zerrung gut sind und die jetzt auch die 2. Liga jetzt noch nicht so aufgesaugt haben bis jetzt. Aber die spielen schon gut. Wie gesagt, da sehe ich eigentlich sehr positiv für den VfB.
Ja, was mich bei Stuttgart überrascht hat, war, man kannte ja so ein bisschen den Tim-Weiter-Fußball. Gerade mir war er auch noch von den Amateuren bekannt. Ein hohes Anlaufen, ein schnelles Umschalten. Und jetzt sehe ich mir aber die Statistik nach 5 gespielten Spielen an. Und keiner kommt dem VfB auch nur annähernd in Sachen Ballbesitz nahe. 63% Ballbesitz, dazu eine hohe Passquote. Und die Spiele, die ich gesehen habe, waren aber trotzdem davon geprägt, dass das eben ähnlich, wie du es vorhin für den HSV beschrieben hast, keinem Ballbesitz um das Ballbesitzwinn war, sondern dass da schon immer das Ziel war, ihn tief durchzustecken, den Ball hinter die letzte Kette zu kommen, einen der schnellen Stürmer zu schicken und dann eben eine Vielzahl an Torchancen herauszuarbeiten, die dann nicht immer verwertet wurden. Das hast du ja auch schon angesprochen. Also ich hatte das Gefühl, da hat sich auch entweder Tim Walter ein bisschen angepasst auf das, was er beim VfB Stuttgart vorfindet, auch ja quasi im Gegnerverhalten, die ja auch sich etwas tiefer reinstellen gegen den Absteiger aus der ersten Liga. Oder dass er vielleicht sogar seine Idee des Fußballs ein bisschen weiter verfeinert hat.
Ja, also da muss ich dir zustimmen. Ich denke mal auch, dass das das Wichtigste ist für einen Trainer, dass er ja auch mit der, dass er nicht starr seine Formation durchdrückt und seinen Stil, sondern sich dem stellt, was er vorfindet. Und als VfB Stuttgart ist man eben wie auch als HSV oder als Köln in der letzten Saison immer Favorit. Und viele Gegner wollen halt gar nicht richtig mitspielen, beziehungsweise eben hoffen dann auf ihre ein, zwei langen Bälle, die durchkommen. Und ich sehe aber auch bei Stuttgart, sie verlieren nicht die Geduld. Also sie haben ja bis jetzt alle ihre Heimspiele 2 zu 1 gewonnen. Da ist auch zum Beispiel nach Rückstand gegen St. Pauli, wo sie dann sehr spät getroffen haben. Sie haben, sie hätten auch beide unentschieden in Heidenheim und in Aue hätten sie auch gewinnen können. Sie waren jeweils überlegen, hatten Chancen. Gegen Heidenheim vielleicht etwas weniger als gegen Aue, weil Heidenheim hatte da auch große Chancen. Aber wenn ich sehe, dass sie schon elf Punkte haben und jetzt die nächsten Wochen sehe, wo sie gegen Regensburg führt, Bielefeld und Wien spielen, da gibt es schon die Möglichkeit, sich ein bisschen so ein Polster zu schaffen. Vor allem, weil die Mannschaften, die ja so als direkten Konkurrenten gegolten haben vor der Saison, da haben sie ja schon ein bisschen was vor. Und das könnte recht schnell gehen. Und dann hat man halt so ein Polster. Das ist in der 2. Liga ja eigentlich in den letzten Jahren immer so gewesen, dass man auch als Meister nicht unendlich viel Vorsprung hatte, jetzt vor dem Regationsteilnehmer oder vor dem 4. Platz. Aber ich sehe da schon, wenn sich da jetzt irgendwie nicht groß was tut, dann sehe ich Stuttgart schon vorne weiterhin. Also bei uns muss man sehen. Wir haben ja gerade gar nicht darüber geredet, dass sich bei uns jemand verletzt hat und wie sich das auswirken könnte. Aber das sehe ich halt auch bei Stuttgart mit den Verletzungen, die es bisher gab, wo dann eben auch Innenverteidiger-Säulen fehlen. Aber letztendlich, wie gesagt, so ein breiter Kader. Ich sehe da eher schon fast das Problem, dass da irgendwelche Spieler sich vielleicht zu wichtig nehmen, so wie Asuka Siba, der eigentlich wechseln wollte. Und wenn man sich aber auch mal diese Spieler durchliest mit Asuka Siba, die da wie Castro, Karasor, Mangala, der letztes Jahr großartig war und zwar. Und ich glaube, ich habe noch irgendjemanden vergessen. Clement, genau, vom Paderborn.
Auch Philipps, finde ich, hat in der Verteidigung bisher sehr gute Spiele gemacht. Und dann hast du halt diese Urgewalt. Da war man Getuka vorne im Spiel. Nicht immer am effizientesten im Verwerten seiner Torchancen. Das hat er aber mit all seinen Nebenleuten eigentlich gemeint, gehört anscheinend gerade ein bisschen beim VfB mit dazu. Aber allein von der physischen Präsenz her, jemand, der den Ball sehr gut abschirmen kann, der hohe Bälle verwerten kann und der dafür dann immer noch erstaunlich stark am Ball ist. Also das ist mir gerade in der Partie gegen Bochum besonders aufgefallen. Da hat man schon gesehen, das ist vom Niveau her definitiv schon zwischen 2. und 1. Liga. Und da gesellen sich dann eben noch ein paar andere Spieler mit dazu. Zusätzlich mit Kobel noch die Torhüterposition so neu besetzt, dass der Torhüter auch sehr, sehr gut mitspielen kann. Also das ist beim Tim Weiterfußball durchaus auch mitgefragt, dass der Torhüter da gut am Ball ist mit dem Fuß. Das hat auch gut geklappt. Und du hast natürlich Jamera gemeint mit dem Auswahl beim HSV, richtig?
Ja genau, Jamra. Wenn wir noch mal ganz kurz darauf zurückkommen wollen. Bei uns sind genau die Außenverteidiger eben die Positionen, die wir überhaupt nicht, wo wir keine Backups haben. Und da hat sich jetzt heute unser Rechtsverteidiger das Wadenbein gebrochen und wird wohl bis zur Winterpause ausfallen. Da muss man mal gucken, wie wir das kompensieren können und ob das vielleicht so der erste Riss in dieser Saison für uns wird.
Da merkt man dann doch, dass ich 2. Liga zwar verfolge, aber viel mit abgeschaltetem Ton. Dann weiß ich nicht, wie man die Spieler richtig ausspricht. Das ist hoffentlich etwas einfacher, wenn wir jetzt über Sandhausen sprechen. Die liegen nämlich auf Platz 3. Und da würde ich jetzt dann schon ein Überraschend noch mit hinzufügen, auch wenn wir jetzt erst 5 Spieltage gespielt haben. Eine Niederlage erst, 7 zu 4 Tore und damit eben 10 Punkte. Was lässt sich zu Sandhausen sagen? Machen die das einfach so wie die ganzen letzten Jahre, dass sie uns permanent überraschen und einfach nicht absteigen wollen aus dieser 2. Liga? Was ist da schon wieder los?
Ja, man muss bei Sandhausen halt wirklich festhalten, dass das mittlerweile grundsolider zweitlig ist, den halt viele gerne noch in den Abstiegskampf schreiben, aber die sich Jahr für Jahr neu erfinden und die ihre Rolle gefunden haben. Im letzten Jahr war man ja auch in der Hinrunde sehr schwach und konnte sich dann durch so einen Schlussspurt mit dem neuen Trainer Uwe Koschinert retten und ersetzt einfach da an, wo sie aufgehört haben. Und natürlich, ich habe das verstanden vor der Saison, dass viele gesagt haben, wird das was bei Sandhausen, wenn man allein schon sieht, dass sie 32 ihrer 45 Tore der Vor-Saison abgegeben haben mit schleusener Wuten. Und jetzt noch mit Förster, den sich der VfB, über den wir gerade gesprochen haben, die den sich geholt haben. Da kann man anhand der aktuellen Tabelle fast schon davon sprechen, dass sie die direkte Konkurrenz schwächen wollen. Und ja, bei Sandhausen fällt mir auf vor allen Dingen die Abwehrkette. Da gucke ich als Hamburger natürlich auch drauf. Die haben ja Dennis Diegmeier als Kapitän, der bei uns lange gespielt hat. Da hat man sich natürlich auch in der letzten Saison gefragt, warum geht er da hin, wie passt er da rein. Aber hat sich gut gemacht, ist Kapitän, ist wohl beliebt. Und zusammen mit Pakarada auf der anderen Seite, dem Linksverteidiger, den ich sehr stark sehe, das sind zwei Spieler mit sehr viel Dampf nach vorne. Und dann haben sie in der Zentrale mit Schirkow und Nauber erfahrene Innenverteidiger, die aber auch noch Entwicklungspotenzial haben. Da sehe ich schon das Fundament als eine grundsolide Defensive. Mit Linzmeier auch noch vor der Abwehr, der als Chef vor der Abwehr alle Löcher stöpft und für Stabilität sorgt. Nicht umsonst haben sie erst 4 Gegentore bis jetzt kassiert.
Ja, das scheint wirklich wieder zumindest jetzt. Der Anfang der Saison ist sehr, sehr positiv für Sandhausen. Und da kann man auch wieder einige ganz überraschende Spielzüge sehen. Also das ist kein Mauerfußball, auch wenn die Tordifferenz von 7 zu 4 sich fast ein bisschen so anhört. Aber ich finde, da ist schon immer ganz gut im Umschaltspiel vor allem Dampf nach vorne drin.
Ja, und Korshin hat selber gesagt ja auch, dass sie den nächsten Schritt machen wollen, dass sie in Richtung leichter Tendenz zur Ballbesitzmannschaft werden wollen. Natürlich auch trotzdem noch schnell nach vorne über die Flügel, eben auch über die starken Außenverteidiger, die antreiben. Und was mir bei Sandhausen imponiert, ist, dass sie sich auch oft ihre Spieler selbst hochziehen. Also sie haben ja Wuten verloren zum Beispiel, der 17 Tore gemacht hat. Und dann ist jetzt einfach Behrens der Stammstürmer, der schon letztes Jahr da war, mehr aber in so einer Backup-Rolle und der jetzt halt im zweiten Jahr den Sprung macht und auch schon drei Tore erzielt hat. Und ja, man muss jetzt halt wirklich gucken. Mit Förster ist wohl so der beste Spieler gegangen, auch der Kreativ-Kopf in der Zentrale Offensiv. Wie sie den ersetzen können, ob Neuzugang Halimi, der gerade dafür gekommen ist, oder Türpitz, ob sie das machen können. Denn also Gießlasshorn und Engels auf den Flügeln und Behrens davor, das alleine, das haut einen natürlich nicht um. Das sind alle Spieler, die ihre Stärken haben. Gießlasshorn mehr so der Tripler, der auf Flanken schlägt, und Engels derjenige, der ein bisschen brachialer nach vorne spielt. Und ja, da muss man schauen. Wie gesagt, das Fundament ist für mich die Defensive. Und wenn sie das schaffen, aus der kompakten Defensive so ein bisschen ein Ballbesitzspiel zu etablieren, dann werden sie auch wieder ihre 40-Plus-Punkte holen.
Also ich muss sagen, das hätte schon eine besondere Ironie, wenn der Verein, der immer so als Synonym für die 2. Liga steht, nämlich dass man den Absteigenden hinterher ruft, haha, ihr müsst jetzt nach Sandhausen fahren, wenn jetzt einfach Sandhausen zu den Erstligisten käme, das wäre irgendwie nett, der Prophet käme zum Berg. Oder umgedreht, je nachdem, wie man das jetzt möchte. Dann lassen wir noch ein paar Vereine herauspicken. Jetzt alle können wir jetzt nicht besprechen in dieser Folge, aber es wird jetzt wieder Kurzpässe geben, nachdem der Kindergarten hier in Bayern jetzt wieder geöffnet ist, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das war der Grund, warum es jetzt erst ein Zweitligakurzpass gibt. Es gibt noch eine Mannschaft, die ebenfalls ungeschlagen ist, nämlich Arminia Bielefeld auf Tabellenplatz 5 aktuell, mit einer relativ spektakulären Tordifferenz von 12 zu 8 Toren. Wie gefällt dir denn die Arminia?
Ja, die Arminia verfolge ich eigentlich immer schon ein bisschen mehr, weil der HSV ja immer so eine Fanfreundschaft mit Bielefeld hatte früher. Das ist ein bisschen eingeschlafen, dieses 3er-KSV Bielefeld Hannover. Aber meine Sympathien liegen bei Bielefeld. Und ja, also hier muss man halt, was für Sandhausen gilt, eben, dass sie so eine eingespielte Truppe haben mit wenig Veränderungen. Und wenn diese Veränderungen kommen, dass man die dann eben intern auffängt. Ich glaube, hier muss man das nochmal ein bisschen mehr betonen. Die haben, glaube ich, gar keinen relevanten Abgang gehabt. Also Innenverteidiger, Burner wäre der einzige, der mir einfällt. Ansonsten ist das komplett die Truppe aus der letzten Saison. Und vorne haben sie vielleicht sogar eines der besten Sturmdos der 2. Liga. Auch wenn Vogelsammer über den Flügel kommt. Aber Vogelsammer und Kloss, die harmonieren ja auch schon seit Jahren hervorragend.
Kloss schon mit 3 Toren, 2 Vorlagen in 5 Spielen, das ist nicht so schlecht?
Das ist nicht so schlecht. Und grundsätzlich kann man bei Bielefeld sagen, sie haben zwar auch eine sehr gute Chancenverwertung im Moment, deswegen haben sie auch schon ihre 12 Tore. Aber das ist eine Mannschaft, die spielerisch auch einiges in die Waagschale legen kann. Eben aus diesem zentralen Mittelfeld. Wo ja, wo Britel und Hartel spielen im Moment. Aber gleichzeitig sind sie halt auch standardstark, eben durch Spieler wie Kloss oder die Innenverteidiger, wenn die nach vorne rücken. Und vor der Saison wurde Bielefeld ja schon von vielen als Geheimfavorit gesehen. Also ich habe eigentlich kaum eine Prognose gesehen, die Bielefeld schlechter als Platz 6 hatte. Eben wahrscheinlich, weil sie die zweitbeste Rückrundenmannschaft der letzten Saison waren und quasi keinen Spieler verloren haben. Und bis jetzt haben sie ja unter Beweis gestellt, dass sie dadurch, dass sie in fünf Spielen noch nicht verloren haben, dass sie zumindest bisher richtig eingeschätzt wurden. Und was halt auch aufgefallen ist, ist die Comeback-Qualität vom Bielefeld. Also sie haben schon dreimal nach Rückstand noch eine Remie geholt. Aber ich habe mich mal umgehört im Bielefeld. Also die rechnen selber natürlich nicht mit dem Aufstieg. Also da sind so die Leute eben aus dem Umland oder die, die die 2. Liga nur am Rande verfolgen, ein bisschen euphorischer. Und das Wort Geheimfavorit käme da wohl etwas zu früh. Aber Bielefeld scheint sich gerade richtig gut zu etablieren, so in den Top 25 bis vielleicht Top 30 in Deutschland. Und das macht doch eigentlich Spaß, so zu sehen.
Absolut. Mit Uwe Neuhaus natürlich auch ein Trainer, der das jetzt schon an verschiedenen Wirkungsstätten gezeigt hat, dass das nicht im Bereich des Unmöglichen liegt, dass er eine Mannschaft eben in solche Tabellenregionen führt, in denen Bielefeld jetzt gerade liegt. Aber dann wollen wir sie jetzt gar nicht verschreien. Lassen wir sie einfach noch geheimer Geheimfavorit bleiben und reden dann am 30. Spieltag nochmal drüber, wenn es dann nur noch der Punkt ist nach oben oder wie auch immer es dann aussieht. Ich würde mit dir gerne auch noch über die Absteiger aus der Fußballbundesliga sprechen. Da begegnet uns auf Platz 9 der 1. FC Nürnberg, der bisher eben eine sehr durchschnittliche Bilanz vorzuweisen hat. 2 Siege, 1 Unentschieden, 2 Niederlagen, 6 zu 9 Tore. Also auch in 5 Spielen nur 6 Tore erzielt. Was sind denn die Probleme beim Club? Und sag jetzt bitte nicht nur Tore schießen.
Nein, natürlich nicht nur Tore schießen. Also bei Nürnberg habe ich so in leichter Form die Probleme wahrgenommen, die Hannover halt auch hat. Nämlich, dass das alles sehr spät entstanden ist, dieses ganze Konstrukt. Also viele Transfers kamen spät. Ich glaube, jemand wie Geiss kam jetzt erst vor ein paar Wochen und soll jetzt der neue Heilsbringer sein im zentralen Mittelfeld. Auch vorne haben sie nochmal nachgelegt mit frei, weil sie eben gesehen haben, dass es nicht zu 100 Prozent läuft. Und grundsätzlich muss man halt auch sagen, die Dreierkette bzw. diese Fünferkette-Variante, die sie spielen, die wirkt sie jetzt noch nicht perfekt einstudiert. Wir haben ja als HSV auch schon in Nürnberg gespielt, vielleicht ein bisschen zu hoch gewonnen mit 4 zu 0. Aber da hat man schon gesehen, dass die Nürnberger sowohl in der Standardverteidigung als auch in der Individualverteidigung sehr viele Fehler gemacht haben und sehr viele einfache Abschlüsse zugelassen haben. Dazu mit Martenian Torwart, den ich ja auch kenne, der für mich so ein bisschen zwischen Genie und Wahnsinn pendelt. Also in der Bundesliga hat er am Ende der letzten Saison sehr gut gehalten und auf der Linie ist er auch einer der besten. Aber ich glaube, er hat jetzt schon bei drei Toren nicht so gut ausgesehen, jeweils durch Fernschüsse bei Standards. Das ist natürlich ein Problem. Und ansonsten haben sie ein bisschen gebraucht, um so ihren Spielstil zu finden. Aber das letzte Spiel gegen Heidenheim, auch wenn sie es nicht gewonnen haben, sondern nur 2 zu 2 gespielt haben, das haben alle gesagt, sowohl Spieler, Trainer als auch Journalisten, die sich das Spiel angeguckt haben. Das war ihr bestes Spiel bisher, wo sie eben zwei Minuten geschlafen haben und so noch ein 2 zu 0 vergeben haben. Also die waren auf Kurs, haben 2 zu 0 geführt. Und da ist man eben auch viel aggressiver zur Werke gegangen, hat das Gegenpressing viel genauer gespielt, ist auch früher raufgegangen und hatte Heidenheim, die ja auch so ein Synonym sind für eine typische Zweitligatruppe, hatten sie eigentlich ziemlich im Griff und haben halt noch die Punkte abgegeben. Aber sieben Punkte aus fünf Spielen ist zwar nicht gut, aber ist auch nicht so schlimm. Also das kann man schon alles noch aufholen.
Klar, sind noch drei Punkte bis zu Sandhausen. Und überhaupt ist ja die Tabelle an sich erstmal eine Momentaufnahme. Also ich entnehme deinen Worten, du erwartest eigentlich, dass das beim Club jetzt alles erst in den nächsten Wochen formt, weil eben der Kader erst so spät fest in seiner Zusammenstellung feststand.
Genau, also da habe ich noch positive Hoffnung für die Klubberer, dass sie noch nach oben aufschließen können. Vielleicht ein bisschen mehr als noch bei dem anderen Absteiger, über den wir gleich noch reden werden.
Dann lass doch gleich über Hannover 96 sprechen, bevor wir uns dann noch kurz mit einem der Aufsteiger befassen wollen. Hannover auf Platz 12. Die haben erst einen Sieg in dieser Zweitligasaison erzielt. Und eben jetzt auch noch kein besonders berühmtes Torverhältnis mit sechs zu sieben Toren. Fünf Punkte gibt das dann am Ende in der Endabrechnung. Was unterscheidet denn deiner Meinung nach Hannover 96 vom Klub?
Also wenn man es ganz böse sagt, dann würde ich sagen, dass bei Hannover sich überhaupt noch gar kein Konzept, was sie überhaupt machen wollen. Du hast ja selber vor der Saison provokant im Zweitligaforum, in deinem Forum gefragt, really, Slomka? Ich würde die Frage eigentlich gerne jetzt nochmal stellen. Also ich verstehe sein Konzept nicht. Er hat eigentlich in jedem Spiel ein bisschen anders aufgestellt, hat immer wieder zwischen Dreier- und Viererketter gewechselt. Und das, wofür er ja früher so berühmt war, dass man irgendwie so in acht Sekunden zum Abschluss kommen muss, das habe ich überhaupt noch gar nicht von Hannover gesehen. Sie hatten natürlich Probleme. Sie haben noch später überhaupt Neuzugänge geholt als Nürnberg. Man kennt ja noch dieses Mannschaftsfoto, was es vor der Saison gab, wo ich glaube, acht Spieler und zwölf Betreuer da vor einer Bande standen. Und man dachte, okay, was geht in Hannover ab? Und ja, man hat jetzt – also ich sehe große Probleme im zentralen Mittelfeld, weil man da eben mit Baccarloz und Prip so Spieler hat, die vor allen Dingen über den Kampf kommen und die über die Leidenschaft kommen, aber die nach vorne jetzt irgendwie Schnittstellenpässe oder große Kreativität im Dribbling sehe ich da überhaupt nicht. Da hat man jetzt mit Stendera jemanden geholt, der das bringen soll, aber gleichzeitig eben auch jemanden via Ogo, der auch im zentralen Mittelfeld eingeplant ist. Und da würde mich vielleicht mal deine Meinung interessieren, ob du glaubst, dass diese beiden Spieler jetzt irgendwie groß Hannover helfen werden.
Ja, gut, schwierig zu sagen. Also ich finde, Stendera ist immer so ein uneingelöstes Versprechen gewesen bei der Eintracht. Und im Grunde hat man ihn nicht so wirklich lang genug gesehen, um das zu beurteilen. Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass er so eine Kittelrolle bei Hannover 96 einnimmt im zentralen Mittelfeld. Aber es ist völlig unseriös, wenn ich jetzt sage, das wird so kommen, weil dafür kenne ich den Spieler zu schlecht. Also ich habe zu wenige Minuten von dem gesehen. Bei Dennis Aogo glaube ich ist es ähnlich wie bei vielen anderen, die man da im Kader finden kann. Oztsolek würde ich da zum Beispiel auch mit reinwerfen. Oder Robert Ziele ist irgendwie auch so eine Kategorie für ein Spiel, auch wenn er jetzt auf einer ganz anderen Position spielt. Das sind gute bis sehr gute Spieler, die immer 10% Ausschnitt haben in ihrem Spiel. Es gibt 10% der Aktionen, die reichen nicht vom Niveau her. Das ist aber in der 2. Liga vielleicht weniger schlimm als in der 1. Liga, weil in der 2. Liga spielen auch beim Gegner sehr häufig Spieler, die einfach in einer von 10 Aktionen etwas individuell nicht ganz Perfektes machen. Es gibt einfach mehr Fehler in der 2. Liga, deswegen fällt das da vielleicht ein bisschen weniger auf. Deswegen kann das funktionieren, auch mit Aogo im defensiven Mittelfeld. Wenn ich mir allerdings im direkten Vergleich jetzt die Kader vom HSV, also vom anderen HSV angucke, vom Hamburger SV, vom VfB mir anschaue. Ich finde auch vom 1. FC Nürnberg bei allen Problemen, die du schon besprochen hast, aber dann sehe ich bei denen noch mehr. Da habe ich jetzt Bielefeld zum Beispiel noch gar nicht mitgenannt. Ansonsten bin ich jetzt schon so ein bisschen am Zweifeln, wie die Qualität bei den anderen Mannschaften ist. Eigentlich hat mir Heidenheim noch sehr gut gefallen vor dieser Saison. Das haben sie bisher noch nicht so wirklich gezeigt. Aber dann finde ich, dass sich da Handrufe 96 allein von der Zusammenstellung des Kaders nicht unter – also befindet sich unter den ersten 6 bis 8 der 2. Liga, aber nicht definitiv unter den ersten 3. Und dann hängt es halt an an so Dingen wie kriegst du deine Abwehr stabilisiert, schießt du Tore nach Standards, bekommst irgendwann mal einen Lauf zum richtigen Zeitpunkt, ob du es irgendwie schaffst, in die Aufstiegsringe zu kommen oder nicht. Aber ich würde es eigentlich gar nicht so sehr an jetzt Aogo festmachen oder an Stendera festmachen, sondern ich finde, die beiden stehen eigentlich relativ stellvertretend für den kompletten Kader. Es ist ein Mix aus erfahrenen, nicht unbedingt überbordend kreativen Spielern. Aber das kann ja auch reichen. Also das hat sich jetzt sehr negativ angehört, aber ich habe es vielleicht gar nicht so negativ gemeint, wie es jetzt gerade rüber kam. Ich meine, du hast zum Beispiel auch noch einen Waldemar Anton, der zwar eine fürchterliche Erstligasaison gespielt hat, aber der auch in dieser Saison, damals, letztes Jahr, immer mal wieder gezeigt hat, was er kann und dass er diese Abwehr auch als Abwehrchef anführen kann. Und das ist zum Beispiel ein Spieler, den haben jetzt nicht so viele andere Zweitligisten.
Bei Anton würde ich auch sagen, dem würde das auch helfen, wenn Slomka sich entscheiden würde, ob er mit Dreierkette oder Viererkette spielen will. Weil man hat zum Beispiel im Spiel gegen den HSV, was ja letztens erst war, gesehen, dass er als linker Abwehrspieler, also linker Abwehrspieler einer Dreierkette, schon sehr damit überfordert war, wann er rauszurücken hat gegen unsere Flügelstürmer und dass er dann auch im Lauftuell nicht gut aussah. Und ich finde, das hat seine Stärken komplett beraubt. Weil von Anton halte ich eigentlich viel. Also das ist ja auch so ein Spieler, der könnte auch aus der Innenverteidigung vielleicht teilweise als Aufbauspieler mehr bringen als Spieler wie Makalurzo oder Prip vor ihm.
Der hat ja schon mal auf der 6 gespielt, für Hannover 96. Da hat er das eigentlich ganz gut gemacht mit dem Spielaufbau. Also du hast quasi einen abkippenden Sechser, ohne dass er abkippen muss. Da steht ja schon die Innenverteidigung.
Genau. Müssen wir mal schauen, ob Slomka das noch hinkriegt. Die Flügelspieler, das ist mir alles ein bisschen dünn, also von der Anzahl der Spieler und auch von der Qualität her. Aber ich finde zum Beispiel auch vorne, das sind alles, sind Stürmer, die sind noch einigermaßen jung, aber können sich noch entwickeln und haben eigentlich auch die Qualität für die 2. Liga. Ich meine, Dux hat es jetzt schon mehrfach gezeigt. Weidand hat es teilweise in der 1. Liga auch schon gezeigt und auch teilweise diese Saison. Und mit Teuchert haben sie dann noch jemanden in der Hinterhand, den man mal bringen kann. Ja, die Frage eben, wie oft kommt man in solche Situationen? Wie oft beißt man sich auch an anderen Mannschaften die Zähne aus, die Hannover eben dem Ball zu schustern?
Ja, also da sehe ich tatsächlich auch noch die größten Fragezeichen im Kader. Also Dux, Weidand, Teuchert und Soto sind so nominell die Mittelstürmer, die du da zur Verfügung hast. Und da ist für mich ehrlich gesagt keiner mit dabei, der für mich Knipser-Qualitäten hat. Und ich glaube, dass die Hannover 96 brauchen wird, wenn ich mir anschaue, dass sie jetzt nach fünf Spieltagen bei den Schüssen in Richtung des gegnerischen Tores auf Platz 14 in der Liga liegen. Also da sind nur noch Heidenheim, Regensburg, Darmstadt und St. Pauli aktuell schlechter. Ja, erst fünf Spiele gespielt, aber eine Tendenz würde ich da jetzt schon mal rauslesen können. Das heißt, so richtig viele Abschlussmöglichkeiten werden die nicht kriegen. Also das ist quasi das Gegenteil zum VfB, wo du nach der vergebenen Großchance weißt, naja gut, im Zweifel spielen wir ja noch zwei raus. Ist ja erst 85. Minute, da geht schon noch was, das kriegen wir schon noch irgendwie hin. Ist bei Hannover 96 dann ein bisschen gravierender. Und da kann jeder der vier, also vor allem Dux und Weidand, die könnten mich vielleicht auch wirklich vom Gegenteil überzeugen und täuchert. Den hat man halt jetzt, er verschwand vom Club aus der Sichtbarkeit, quasi bei Schalke 04. Man weiß nicht, was in der Zwischenzeit mit ihm passiert ist. Aber nur von den Namen her und von dem, was ich da bisher gesehen habe, würde ich sagen, das könnte das größte Problem werden. Wer soll vorne die Tore schießen? Wir werden uns einfach überraschen lassen, würde ich sagen. Überrascht hat ja auch einer der Aufsteiger, nämlich der KSC, der nämlich eigentlich, wenn wir jetzt streng nach Tabelle gegangen wären, nach dem Club und vor Hannover 96 gekommen wäre. Die liegen aktuell auf Platz 10 und waren auch schon viel, viel besser postiert. Zwei Siege, drei Niederlagen, neun zu zwölf Tore. Ist das so dieser klassische Effekt gewesen? Der Aufsteiger kommt hoch und ist dann besonders euphorisch. Und so kommen dann auch die Siege zustande. Wie würdest du das einordnen, was wir da beim KSC gesehen haben bisher?
Ja, also die beiden Siege waren gegen Wien und Dürnheim und Dresden. Da hat man erstmal gegen einen Mitaufsteiger gespielt. Da sollte man immer eine Chance haben. Und dann gegen Dürnheim und Dresden, die ich für eine der seltsamsten Mannschaften der zweiten Liga halte bis jetzt, weil die haben so unfassbar viel Ballbesitz und machen oft so wenig daraus und werden immer vom Gegner dazu gezwungen. Grundsätzlich finde ich das bei Karlsruhe sehr interessant, dass sie so einen ganz klaren Spielstil haben. Die spielen so viel Langholz auf Hofmann. Wenn wir von Säulen oder Schlüsselspielern reden, dann müssen wir erst mal über Hofmann reden. Was vielleicht so ein Spieler wäre, wenn du den jetzt bei Hannover drin hättest, vielleicht wärst du dann schon positiver gestimmt. Der gewinnt im Spiel neun Kopfballduelle. Wir haben das gesehen, als der KSC gegen uns gespielt hat, gegen den HSV, dass sie eigentlich vom Institut 1 an ihn gesucht haben und dann spätestens, als sie hinten lagen und einen Sturmlauf gemacht haben, dass da Flanke um Flanke in unseren Strafraum kamen. Und das hat ja auch zweimal funktioniert. Bei Karlsruhe an sich sieht man eben auch, was es ausmachen kann. Wenn man so eine Konstanz im Kader hat, obwohl man die Liga wechselt, haben sie bis jetzt erst 17 Spieler eingesetzt. Das ist nicht so viel, da gibt es auch Mannschaften, die haben schon 23 Spieler eingesetzt. Die Aufstellung ist eigentlich in Stein gemeißelt. Da haben sie nicht viel gewechselt. Sie werden jetzt vielleicht dazu gezwungen, dadurch, dass sich Rosbach, der Linksverteidiger, verletzt hat. Aber das ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass dann irgendwie alles auseinander bricht. Wobei bei 12 Gegentoren man ja sowieso nicht sagen kann, dass Karlsruhe da die sicherste Abwehr von allen Mannschaften hätte.
Andererseits ja allein vier davon gegen den HSV in einem Spiel, wo man nach 0 zu 3 ja noch auf 2 zu 3 rangekommen ist. Und dann der vierte Treffer ganz kurz vor Schluss oder in der Nachspielzeit, glaube ich, in so einer Einzelaktion dann gefallen ist. Da stand man eigentlich ganz gut, aber dieses eine HSV-Spiel reißt dann auch so ein bisschen raus, oder?
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Du hast ja dann trotzdem noch in den anderen vier Spielen 8 Tore kassiert. Also das sind immer noch zwei pro Spiel.
Ja gut, aber wenn du heute 4 zu 2 gegen Dresden gewinnst, 2 zu 1 gegen Wien und ja gut gegen Heustank hier nochmal zwei kassiert. Ja okay, vielleicht sind da auch einfach fünf Spiele noch nicht genug, um das zu bewältigen.
Nee, absolut. Aber man sieht das ja schon von den Namen. Also die Aufsteiger – in den letzten Jahren in der zweiten Liga gab es ja eigentlich immer einen Aufsteiger, der ziemlich lange oben mitgespielt hat. Und ich hatte eigentlich auch vor der Saison gedacht, dass es eher Karlsruhe ist als Osnabrück und Wien. Eben weil das so eine gefestigte Mannschaft ist, wo sich irgendwie, wenn man da so die ernstzunehmenden Kaderspieler betrachtet, irgendwie wurden da fünf neu geholt und fünf abgegeben. Nur das andere waren alles eher unrelevante Leihspieler. Ja, wie gesagt, die Frage ist eben, ob dieser klare Spielstil, den Karlsruhe hat, mit diesen ständigen Flanken und Langholz, ob das irgendwann eben einfach zu leicht zu verteidigen ist. Weil jetzt, das hat gegen HSV zum Beispiel sehr gut funktioniert, aber wir sind auch eines der schwächsten Kopfball-Teams in der Liga. Also, bis auf unsere Innenverteidiger kann bei uns eigentlich niemand den Kopfball-Duellen dauerhaft dagegenhalten. Aber, ich sag mal so, die meisten Mannschaftsteile sind einfach grundsolide aufgestellt, aber nicht besonders breit. Das heißt, wenn man auch Pech hat und sich zum Beispiel Hoffmann oder Warnizek im Mittelfeld, der so ein bisschen der Kreativdirektor ist, wenn sich da jemand verletzt, können die schnell einbrechen. Drei Niederlagen in Folge machen mir auch ein bisschen Sorge. Ich hatte da, wie gesagt, eigentlich sie auch als Überraschungsteam auf Platz 7 bis 9 getippt. Kann natürlich alles noch kommen. Ich meine, wir sind sehr früh.
Ja, aber gerade das 0-3 in Osnabrück war natürlich schon sehr deutlich. Also, über Osnabrück haben wir jetzt nicht länger gesprochen. Das wird sicher in einem der nächsten Kurzpässe zur 2. Liga mal der Fall sein. Aber ich fand diese Niederlage in Osnabrück, die war auch vom Ergebnis her in Ordnung. Da war Osnabrück einfach deutlich besser als der KSC und hat verdienter 3-0 gewonnen.
Also Karlsruhe hat halt so, finde ich, natürliche Limitierung irgendwann. Also dieses ganze Spiel mit den Flanken, das kannst du halt zwar perfektionieren, aber der Gegner kann sich halt darauf einstellen. Und irgendwann wirst du nicht mehr höher springen können oder besser flanken können. Und ja, Aloe Schwarz, der Trainer, der hat ja auch schon viel 2. Liga gesehen und überall seinen 4-4-2 mitgebracht. Ich habe jetzt gelesen, dass sie das vielleicht umstellen wollen auf eine Doppel-6, eben um die Verteidigung ein bisschen zu verbessern und da ein bisschen Sicherheit rein zu bekommen. Wahrscheinlich wird Karlsruhe im untere Mittelfeld landen, so wie es aktuell aussieht. Aber das ist halt sehr früh.
Sehr früh für Prognosen. Und Aloe Schwarz trifft jetzt dann am Freitagabend auf Sandhausen, seine alte Station. Solche Geschichten schreibt ausschließlich der Fußball. Welche Geschichten hat denn der Fußball bei St. Pauli geschrieben, die du ja nicht nur wegen deiner räumlichen Nähe zu St. Pauli im Blick haben wirst, sondern sicher auch wegen des Derbys, was jetzt am Montag ansteht. Wenn ich mir einfach nur die Bilanz angucke, nämlich ein Sieg, zwei Unentschieden, das heißt fünf Punkte, acht zu zehn Tore, aktuell Platz 13, dann steht ja St. Pauli schon ganz schön unter Druck.
Ja, und St. Pauli hat sich ja vor der Saison schon ein bisschen selber die Eier ins Nest gelegt, als Luhukai vor der Saison schon erste Brandreden gehalten hat und darauf hingewiesen hat, dass ihm der Kader zu dünn ist. So hat man sehr viele Spieler sehr spät geholt, die meisten auf Leihbasis und hat jetzt einen der breitesten Kader der Liga. Und wenn die ganzen Verletzten, die es zweifelsfrei gab und gibt, wenn die zurückkommen, dann kannst du da fast schon zwei Trainingsspiele gleichzeitig abhalten. Sankt Pauli selber, ja, was soll ich da groß zu sagen? Die spielen eigentlich immer so ein bisschen den gleichen Stiefel in der 2. Liga. Und ich finde, es hängt so ein bisschen an der Liga, ob sie weiter oben oder weiter unten spielen. Im letzten Jahr waren sie ja lange oben dabei. Aber ich glaube, das lag eher daran, dass ich die anderen Teams, dass ich da keiner wirklich absetzen konnte oder so. Also St. Pauli, grundsolide. So wirklich als neutraler Zuschauer hat man bis jetzt, glaube ich, nicht viel Spaß gehabt, wenn man vielleicht jetzt vom 3 zu 3 gegen Dresden absieht. Denn was du irgendwie zu Hannover gesagt hast, mit den wenigen Torschüssen, das kann man bei St. Pauli, glaube ich, noch mal ein bisschen potenzieren. Niemand hat weniger. Genau, sie haben erst 11 Schüsse, glaube ich, pro Spiel. Und auch nur 3 aufs Tor. Also das ist wenig. Was auffällt, finde ich, ist, dass sie zwei der vielleicht aufregendsten Spieler der Liga bis jetzt in ihren Reihen haben. Zum einen der Jungspieler Conte. Das ist ein Flügelspieler, der ist blitzschnell und sorgt eigentlich immer Leingang dafür, dass St. Pauli Kontergefahr ausstrahlt. Vielleicht irgendwie so eine Light-Version von Luca Barca aus dem letzten Jahr, wenn man das so ein bisschen vergleichen will. Der hat jetzt auch eigentlich immer entweder getroffen, gute Szenen aufgelegt oder wie jetzt unter der Woche, als er reingekommen ist am letzten Spieltag, dort immerhin eine rote Karte rausgeholt, einfach durch seine Schnelligkeit. Und Mats Möller-Dali, das ist so ein Kreativspieler, von dem man sich fragt, ob er nicht irgendwann vielleicht noch mal in die Bundesliga oder in irgendeine andere erste Liga wechseln wollen würde, weil der sich seit Jahren ja von seinem Potenzial und seinen Fähigkeiten ein bisschen abhebt, aber immer wieder so lethargische Phasen hat.
Ja, vom Freiburg lange an St. Pauli ausgeliehen und jetzt fest verpflichtet, hat schon fünf Vorlagen zu Toren gegeben und ein Tor selbst erzielt. Das ist bei den wenigen Chancen, die St. Pauli ja pro Spiel rausholt, dann wirklich ganz, ganz beachtlich, Mats Müller-Dali.
Genau, wenn wir vielleicht noch mal darauf eingehen, auf diese wenigen Schüsse, dann muss man doch sagen, dass mit Fehrmann und Taschi zwei weitere Sturstürmer bisher überhaupt nicht zum Einsatz kommen konnten, aufgrund von Verletzung und dass Diamantakos auf sich allein gestellt war ein bisschen. Er hat das gut gemacht, immerhin schon drei Tore erzielt. Aber ich glaube, wenn jemand wie Fehrmann vorne drin wäre mit seiner Präsenz und auch trotz seiner Größe seiner technischen Klasse, dann hätte man da einen viel besseren Wandspieler und da könnten auch die Flügelspieler um ihn herum ungemein profitieren. Und da muss man eben sehen, St. Pauli, wie gesagt, durch diesen breiten Kader, die rotieren sehr viel, die haben noch nicht ihre Aufstellung gefunden. Als ich eben davon gesprochen habe, dass einige Mannschaften schon sehr viele Spieler eingesetzt haben, da habe ich halt auch St. Pauli gemeint. Eben durch Verletzungen, also Spieler sind auch wie Avevor schon ausgefallen, aber 23 Spieler schon eingesetzt. Und obwohl man halt so einen großartigen Konterspieler wie Conte in seiner Mannschaft hat, hat man schon viermal geführt, aber nur einmal den Sieg ins Ziel gebracht und die meisten Gegentore haben sie in der zweiten Halbzeit kassiert.
Und da waren ganz merkwürdige Spiele mit dabei. Also das 1 zu 1 in Bielefeld zum Auftakt auf der Alm, das war so ein eher normales Zweitligaspiel. Aber dann zu Hause gegen Greuther Fürth, 1 zu 3 verloren, in Lübeck, erst im Elfmeterschießen weitergekommen im DFB-Pokal, okay, kannst du jetzt HSV aufhören und sagen, passiert dem besten, okay, streichen wir. Aber dann in Stuttgart einen Bus von der Größe des Saarlandes, vor dem eigenen Tor geparkt, 1 zu 0 ganz lange geführt, aber trotzdem dann 2 zu 1 verloren, und zwar auch richtig mit Recht, weil sich St. Pauli eigentlich kaum in diesem Spiel beteiligt hat, dann immerhin gegen Heustern Kiel zu Hause gewonnen, das war eins der besseren Spiele. Und dann jetzt eben dieses recht dramatische 3 zu 3 gegen Dresden in Überzahl. Also das ist irgendwie eine sehr wankelmütige Mannschaft von St. Pauli und so ganz habe ich ehrlich gesagt auch noch nicht verstanden, was Luhukai mit dieser Mannschaft erreichen möchte. Also ich erkenne da keinerlei Stil.
Ja und es ist halt auch so, dass da auf dem letzten Drücker noch sehr viele Spieler auf eine Position geliehen wurden, die schon breit besetzt waren. Und man eben auch noch solche Spieler wie Shahin oder Buchtmann hat, die kaum eine Rolle bisher gespielt haben. Und dann verschiebt man Knoll immer munter zwischen Sechser- und Innenverteidigung hin und her. Ich glaube, da fehlen Automatismen und da fehlt irgendwie die Grundidee, wie man jetzt genau mit welchem Personal das angehen will.
Mal sehen, ob man da dann eine Antwort gefunden hat, jetzt am Montag im Derby gegen den HSV. Werden wir beide sehr genau verfolgen. Lass uns noch über eine Mannschaft sprechen, wo es auch schon den ersten Trainerwechsel gab. Der VfL Bochum liegt mit zwei Punkten aktuell auf Platz 17, hat eben erst zwei Unentschieden geholt, ist zusammen mit Wiesbaden, dem Aufsteiger, die einzige Mannschaft in der zweiten Liga, die noch nicht gewinnen konnte. Robin Dutt hat sich selbst angesägt, hat seinen eigenen Trainerstuhl angesägt und dann am Ende auch gesagt, ich gehe auch in einer bemerkenswerten Pressekonferenz. Was ist da los beim VfL?
Bochum, das ist auch seit Jahren eigentlich immer ein ähnliches Spiel in der 2. Liga. Ambitioniertes Mittelfeld-Team, wo man immer sagt, wenn sie eine gute Saison spielt, können sie nach oben kommen. Die sich dann immer mal so selber ins Bein schießen. Und Robin Dutt hat jetzt ja auch schon in der letzten Rückrunde nicht das Allermeiste aus diesem Kader rausgeholt. Und das hat sich jetzt fortgesetzt und hat sich quasi selber entlassen, wie du ja auch schon gesagt hast. Das ist natürlich irgendwie schwer, das in Worte zu fassen. Wenn man sich auch die Spiele anguckt, sie haben schon zweimal 3 zu 3 zu Hause gespielt.
Immerhin zurückgekommen.
Ja, aber dann habe ich wieder so Spiele wie bei uns, bei HSV, wo sie quasi gar nichts machen über 90 Minuten. Wo sie einfach nur hinten drin stehen. Also wenn sie quasi als Anadoc spielen, keine Spielidee, habe ich da gesehen. Außer der sehr gute Grand Voullard als Sturzstürmer. Ich glaube, das, was du vorhin über den Stuttgarter Stürmer gesagt hast, kann man auch über ihn sagen. Das ist wirklich eine Maschine vorne. Also der kann den Ball halten, der reibt sich richtig auf. Als ich das gesehen habe gegen van Drongelen im Spiel gegen HSV, das haben schnell alle gesehen, dass das das Spannendste an dem Spiel sein wird, wer sich da von den beiden durchsetzt und der sowohl trifft als auch einigermaßen gute Pässe ablegen kann auf die Mannspieler.
Drei Tore, zwei Vorlagen bisher.
Eben, und da sind auch echt schöne Pässe dabei gewesen. Aber wie gesagt, mir fehlte da komplett der Spielstil, also gegen irgendwie gleichstarke Gegner, komplett irgendwie alle Scheuntore auf und 3 zu 3 und dann irgendwie Bus parken, was auch nicht funktioniert hat. Ich hatte so ein bisschen das Gefühl, wie zum Beispiel gegen Wien, Wiesbaden, wo sie ja auch vom 0 zu 3 zurückgekommen sind, glaube ich, dass sie so zu ihrem Glück gezwungen werden mussten, dadurch, dass sie erst so einen Rückstand hatten und dann einfach angelaufen sind. Und dann Spieler wie Ozay Tutu eingewechselt haben, der ja auch beim HSV im Gespräch war, ein Außenspieler, der aus England kommt, der eigentlich als Rechtsverteidiger kommen sollte, aber den man jetzt glaube ich eher offensiver einsetzt, weil die Offensivqualitäten sehr hoch sind, die Defensivqualitäten ein bisschen zu wünschen lassen, übrig lassen. Aber das Problem bei Bochum ist halt auch, dadurch, dass sie jetzt schon den Trainer gewechselt haben, aber man noch nichts von dem neuen Trainer gesehen hat, weiß man natürlich nicht so wirklich, wohin geht die Reise. Also ich kenne Herrn Reis jetzt nicht wirklich.
War das jetzt auch schon ein Wortspiel mit Thomas Reis, wohin geht die Reise? Du bist endlich im Rasenfunk angekommen, Patrick. Jetzt haben wir es geschafft.
Kurz vor Schluss. Ich habe gelesen, er präferiert so ein 4-3-3 oder 4-3-1-2, aber ja, man muss gucken, was man mit dem Kader spielen kann. Da fehlen mir so die klaren Flügelspieler. Jetzt haben sie kurz vor Schluss, weil sie gar kein Budget mehr haben und haben sie noch Winzheimer von uns ausgeliehen, der vielleicht um Gonvular so ein bisschen rumwirbeln kann, so als Halbstürmer, falls sie es mal mit zwei Stürmern probieren wollen. Aber da muss man jetzt einfach abwarten, was sie da abliefern wollen. Grundsätzlich sehe ich Bochum solide aufgestellt, in der Abwehr etwas dünn aufgestellt. Im Mittelfeld haben sie noch im Moment ein paar Verletzungs-Sorgen mit Li und Weiland. Wenn die zurückkommen, könnte sich das da besser gestalten. Aber so eine richtige Truppe für oben sind sie, glaube ich, von Anfang an nicht gewesen. Ob sie jetzt unbedingt absteigen müssen, da gehe ich auch mal nicht von aus. Aber man hat ja in der letzten Saison gesehen, dass nominell gut besetzte Teams wie zum Beispiel Ingolstadt schnell mal länger in den Strudel reinrutschen und dann auch absteigen können. Von daher möchte ich da keine Prognose treffen.
Musst du jetzt auch nicht. Nach fünf gespielten Spielen, da haben wir jetzt noch viel, was wir sehen können. Also Thomas Reis, wem der Name bekannt vorkommt. Er war schon mal als Spieler acht Jahre beim VfL, dann als U19-Trainer, ist zu U19 vom VfL Wolfsburg gewechselt, hat da jeweils die Staffel der Bundesliga Nord-Nord-Ost gewonnen und ist jetzt zurückgekommen zum VfL. Will alles ein bisschen kompakter stehen lassen. Das müssen wir uns dann einfach angucken, wie das jetzt aussieht. Der VfL spielt am Sonntag gegen Dynamo Dresden zu Hause. Dann können wir ja sehen, ob wir auch schon was Neues entdecken. Soll ich dir noch zum Abschluss meine Lieblingsstatistik aus der 2. Liga zitieren, Patrick? Du hast eh keine andere Wahl. Gewonnene Kopfball-Duelle pro Spiel. 3 Spieler, Kevin Behrens von Sandhausen, hast du vorhin schon angesprochen, gewinnt 9 Kopfball-Duelle pro Spiel. Philipp Hoffmann hast du auch angesprochen vom KSC, gewinnt 8 Kopfball-Duelle pro Spiel. Und Silvea Ganvola, über den wir gerade gesprochen haben, 7, 5 Kopfball-Duelle pro Spiel. Und ich möchte das kurz in Relation setzen. In der 1. Fußball-Bundesliga sind Anthony Modest, Mats Hummels und Niklas Völkruck die erfolgreichsten Kopfballspieler mit 6, 7, 6, 3 und 6, 3 gewonnen. Da ist die Samplesize noch ein bisschen kleiner. Aber das zeigt zum einen ein bisschen, wie der Ball gespielt wird in der 2. Liga, nämlich gerne auch mal hoch. Und zum anderen aber auch, welche Qualität diese 3 Spieler hatten, die du eben auch alle angesprochen hast deswegen. Fand ich das jetzt irgendwie ganz nett, ist mir noch aufgefallen. Patrick, ich danke dir sehr, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast für diesen Rasenfunk-Zweitliga-Kurzpass. Wir werden über die anderen Mannschaften, die jetzt nicht erwähnt wurden, sicher in den nächsten Wochen noch sprechen. Also hold your horses oder meldet euch im Forum an unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Es gibt einen sehr, sehr interessanten Zweitliga-Thread, der wesentliche Informationsgrundlage für mich zum Beispiel ist. Herzlichen Dank dafür an alle Forumsmitglieder, die da mitschreiben. Und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich bald wieder. Patrick, danke dir, dass du mit dabei warst.
Ja, danke nochmal für die Einladung. Hat Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich sehr. Mir auch. Man kann dir folgen als at saurehefe1887 auf Twitter und natürlich auch unter gleichem Namen im Rasenfunk-Forum. Und das war er, der 1. Zweitliga. Kurzpass dieser Saison. Endlich ist er draußen. Ihr könnt aufhören nachzufragen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Jetzt haben wir es doch geschafft. Und die 2. Liga wird jetzt immer mal wieder beleuchtet werden. Ansonsten geht es jetzt weiter mit einer Schlusskonferenz. Die erscheint dann am Montagnachmittag. Bis dahin wünsche ich euch eine wunderbare Zeit. Und viel Spaß mit allen Spielen der 2. oder welcher Liga auch immer. Macht's gut, ciao.